[Musique]
bonjour Covelli merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation d'être avec
nous pendant une demi-heure vous êtes
sénateur des hautes scèes memes du
groupe RDPI ce sont les sénateurs de la
majorité présidentielle et hier soir
vous étiez donc à l'Élysée Emmanuel
Macron vous a convié avec tous les
parlementaires de la majorité que vous a
dit le chef de l'État déjà il nous a
présenter ses vœux c'est on est dans la
période et puis il nous a demandé aussi
d'être fier des mesures et des lois que
nous avons porté en 2023 des malgré une
majorité relative nous avons réussi à
faire plus de lois 19 lois dans les 19
premiers mois plus que autant que le
précédent quinena donc effectivement
avec beaucoup d'initiatives
parlementaire un peu moins d'initiative
gouvernementale mais ce qui nous a
permis en tout cas d'avoir des lois de
programmation importantes aussi lois de
programmation sur le ministère de
l'Intérieur sur les armées sur la
justice qui a permis de réarmer aussi
notre pays pour les pour les les
prochaines années les 5 prochaines
années donc oui c'était à la fois une
une demande d'être fier de ce notre
travail et puis de dresser un petit peu
la feuille de route pour pour 2024
notamment sur les questions d'énergie de
logement de travail et avec bien sûr des
textes importants de progrès comme l'IVG
dans la constitution ou mais quelle est
cette feuille de route est-ce qu'il vous
en a dit plus sur le c'est ce que je
viens de vous dire c'est-à-dire qu'il
nous a parlé des grands textes ceux que
nous allons défendre porter ce qu'on
connaît déjà et il vous laisse la
primeur ce soir à la conférence de
presse pour vous donner un peu la
feuille de route sur le rarmement de la
France qui qu'il souhaite il a également
appelé ses troupes à garder leur unité
est-ce que ça viser l'aile gauche de la
majorité dont vous faites partie non il
a parlé euh il parlé d'unité en général
de la majorité et je rappelle quand même
que après 7 ans de mandat du Président
de la République il est encore en
capacité d'élargir sa majorité et on le
voit avec l'arrivée de nouvell
personnalité qui n'était pas en soutien
au président de la République depuis
2017 même pas pas d'ailleurs depuis 2022
et qui rentre aujourd'hui dans la
majorité qui rentre dans le gouvernement
et donc ce qui prouve bien qu'on est
encore en capacité d'élargir notre
majorité ce qui n'est pas rien dans la
situation actuelle et avec une majorité
relative c'est notre rôle le dépassement
c'est dans l'ADN du macronisme c'est
dans l'ADN de ce que porte Emmanuel
Macron depuis 2017 et donc oui il a dit
qu'on avait à la fois des sensibilités
différentes mais le dépassement c'était
pas l'effacement et qu'il fallait
respecter toutes les sensibilités et
qu'il s'attelait en tout cas à faire en
sorte que laj
dans sa diversité puisse être rassemblé
mais parmi les les personnalités dont
vous parlez il a rachti qui est issu DLR
qui avait une place importante dans
l'organigramme DLR est-ce que vous qui
venez du PS vous dites ce gouvernement
il penche trop à droite je je pense pas
qu'il penche trop à droite éc duporti a
une sensibilité plutôt de gauche Prisc
Teven le Premier ministre vient aussi de
la gauche donc on voit bien que
globalement c'est c'est équilibré
annoncé il y en a H qui viennent de R de
la droite donc il y en a si qui viennent
de la gauche donc on pourrait se dire
que à un PR c'est relativement équilibré
et puis il y aura aussi les secrétaires
d'État et les ministres délégés qui vont
arriver moi je souhaite qu'il puisse
avoir effectivement un rééquilibrage que
l'ensemble des sensibilités qu'elle soit
du MoDem d'horizon de territoire de
progrès puisse être représenté dans dans
ce gouvernement ça c'est le choix du
président de la République mais ce qui
est important c'est encore avant tout de
faire ce dépassement de faire en sorte
d'avoir un projet celui du président de
la République celui pour qui il a été
pour lequel il a été élu en 2017 et en
2022 et je pense que c'est ça
l'important parce que si on reste pas
uni et c'est d'ailleurs les mots du
président de la République hier si nous
ne restons pas unis si nous n'arrivons
pas encore à faire ce dépassement et à
élargir ce bloc central ce sont les
extrêmes qui seront aux responsabilités
les prochaines présidentielles que ce
soit extrême droite ou extrême gauche et
je pense que les Français n'en veulent
pas territoire de progrès dont vous
parlez c'est le le le parti en tout cas
la franche qui représente l'elle gauche
de la majorité c'est Olivier du sopte
qui est à sa tête qui a été écarté du
gouvernement est-ce que vous n'avez pas
l'impression d'avoir été un peu malmené
dans ce gouvernemental vous savez moi je
voulais saluer l'action de d'Olivier D
qui apporté des réformes courageuses
nécessaires pour le pays mais parfois
impopulairire euh il a il est resté
quasiment 6 ans et demi en tant que
membre du gouvernement et donc moi je
veux saluer son action il a fait un gros
travail le président de la République
l'a salué à plusieurs reprises justement
pour son travail mais vous regrettez
qu'il a été écarté à titre personnel moi
je regrette mais encore une fois on
n'est pas ministre àe euh c'est un choix
du président de la République et du
Premier ministre euh il Olivier DUT est
toujours président de territoire de
progrès il va redevenir député et moi je
lui prédis d'avoir un un avenir encore
pour servir notre pays comme il le fait
depuis maintenant plusieurs années il y
aura pas un avant et un après au sein de
la majorité avant après cette nomination
du gouvernement àal je pense pas je
pense pas parce que vous savez il y a
une prise de conscience importante
aujourd'hui de ce bloc central qui est
la majorité présidentielle de du risque
de l'extrême droite du risque de de
l'arrivée de Marine Le Pen au
responsabilités et donc nous avons pour
l'intérêt du pays pour l'intérêt des
Français nous avons une nécessité de
nous unir et de travailler on on ne fera
pas forcément toujours on sera pas
toujours d'accord sur tout et on l'a
démontré sur un certain nombre de textes
mais ce qui est important c'est de faire
avancer la France de continuer à
réformer et de trouver des compromis
parfois sur des textes alors bien sûr on
n'ura pas forcément le texte celui qui
nous plaît initialement mais le fait
d'avoir ses compromis ça nous permet de
continuer à faire avancer la France et
pour éviter que les extrêmes arrivent au
pouvoir hier parmi tous les tous les
parlementaires députés et sénateurs qui
étaient réunis à l'Élysée aucun n'a fait
part de son mécontentement au chef de
l'État sur la composition du
gouvernement et sur la ligne c'est c'est
c'est pas le lieu c'est pas le lieu pas
pas une cérémonie de vœux il y a des
échange certainement avec certains
parlementaires et le président de la
République chacun peut exprimer son so
on on n'est pas dans une caporilisation
de la majorité présidentielle mais
encore une fois le choix de des membres
du gouvernement c'est le président de la
République qui nomme sur proposition du
Premier ministre et donc c'est un
travail d'équilibre entre les
différentes sensibilités de la majorité
et c'est ce que aujourd'hui Gabriel
Attal et le président de la République
font mais le fait que ni François Baayou
ni Édouard Philippe n'était présent hier
soir il faut pas y voir un signe pas du
tout c'était les parlementaires qui
étaient conviés et les membres du
gouvernement Édouard Philippe et
François berou ne sont pas membres du du
gouvernement il y avait pourtant ils ne
sont pas membres du gouvernement ni
parement et et donc il y avait malgré
tout des membres d'horizon il sont
président des partis qui composent la
majorité il y avait oui enfin Stéphane
sjourn nétait pas là non plus il était
pour autant membre du gouvernement et
président de parti politique il est en
dépl avait il y avait encore une fois
des membres d'horizon des membres du
MoDem des parlementaires de ces deux
composantes Renaissance bien sûr
territoire de progrès il y avait toutes
les composantes de la majorité hier le
Parti radical également donc vous voyez
que toutes les sensibilités de la
majorité étaient représenté mais les
chefs de parti n'étaient pas forcément
convié plusieurs membres de l'elle
gauche qui n'ont pas été reconduit au
gouvernement on parlait d'Olivier du SOP
mais il y en a d'autres notamment
Clément bon par exemple redeviendront
députés est-ce que vous craignez qu'il
constitue un groupe à part à l'assemblée
nationale c'est c'est forcément il y a
il y a des discussions il y a eu des des
discussions sur sur le sujet après il
faut voir l'intérêt si si l'intérêt de
créer un groupe à gauche nous permet de
continuer ce dépassement de continuer
cet élargissement de la majorité
présidentielle en récupérant et en
essayant d'inciter un certain nombre de
parlementaires issus de la gauche dit
républicaine ou de gouvernement à
rejoindre la majorité présidentielle
pourquoi pas mais ça veut dire que vous
vous le souhaitez la constitution de ce
groupe de gauche de la majorité je dis
qu'il faut que ça soit utile à la
majorité présidenti si on crée un groupe
pour fracturer la majorité je ne vois
pas l'utilité si on crée un groupe pour
élargir la majorité là ça peut être
utile à la fois au président de la
République à la majorité présidentielle
et donc à la France é lgir à qui est-ce
que vous appelez les socialistes qui ne
sont pas favorables à Jean-Luc Mélenchon
à vous rejoindre et à rejoindre ce
groupe mais on le fait depuis le début
et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que nous
nous avons quitté la gauche dite de
gouvernement qui avait perdu justement
son ADN de responsabilité parce que
justement elle était mélanchonisée et
elle allait vers vers Mélenchon et
l'extrême GAE gauche et donc oui nous
appelons et nous continuons à appeler
tous les socio-démocrates tous les
progressistes qui se reconnaissent
aujourd'hui dans un bloc central pour
l'intérêt de la France qui sont
proeuropéens le débat sur les
européennes va être va être particulier
parce que effectivement quand on nous
l'ADN de de la macronie c'est aussi
l'Europe c'est avant tout l'Europe et
donc nous nous souhaitons respecter les
traités européens nous souhaitons
élargir l'Europe nous souhaitons
continuer à travailler pour l'Europe
aujourd'hui les socio-démocrates qui et
les progressistes qui étaient sur cette
ligneel sont alliés national avec
l'extrême gauche qui sont anti-Europe et
donc il va falloir aussi qu'il puisse
clarifier cette situation donc nous nous
appelons effectivement tous les
progressistes tous les sociau-démocrates
à rejoindre la majorité présid mais
est-ce que la droitisation de ce
gouvernement ça ne donne pas plutôt
envie aux sociau-démocrates de revenir
vers le Parti socialiste mais justement
plus ils viendront plus on pourra
rééquilibrer il y a pas une droitisation
il y a pas une droitisation aujourd'hui
quand on voit le bilan de la majorité
présidentielle quand on voit les projets
notamment sur la question de la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG sur la
question de la fin de vie ce sont des
des progrès nouveaux que que la gauche
de gouvernement porte depuis des années
que nous nous portons également à
territoire de progrès et donc c'est sur
ces projets là qu'il faut se rassembler
pour l'intérêt des Français vous parliez
des européennes le chef de l'État vous a
appelé hier je crois la mobilisation
pour ces européennes est-ce que la
majorité tarde trop à se mettre en ordre
de marche non je pense que les les
Français ne sont pas encore dans le
débat des européennes il y a aussi c'est
toute cette construction que nous
faisons à là tout le monde a sa tête de
l sa vous oui d'accord mais enfin bon
est-ce que ça empêche les Français dans
de de de savoir qu'effectivement ils
vont voter entre le rassemblement
national le le groupe renaissance et la
majorité présidentielle ou d'autres
partis politiques la réalité c'est que
les Français ne sont pas encore dans le
débat des européennes il y a un temps
pour tout aujourd'hui il y a une
construction d'un projet il y a la mise
en place d'un nouveau gouvernement qui
va réarmer la France et qui va aussi
porter un certain nombre de nos valeurs
à l'échelle européenne c'est ce que nous
avons démontré ces ces derniers mois et
donc oui il y aura le temps de la
campagne européenne on y est pas encore
mais Jordane Bardella il est déjà en
campagne il a 10 points d'avance sur
vous selon les sondages est-ce que vous
payez pas le fait de ne pas être parti
européen il peut aussi s'occuper de son
mandat et ne pas forcément tout de suite
est en campagne nous nous
comptons travailler avec les Français
sur la préparation de ce programme c'est
ce que nous avonscé et avec qui puisque
Stéphane séjourné était votre tête de
list pressentil il est maintenant en
cador ça les chefs de parti à la fois
Édouard Philippe Stéphane séjourné et
François Berrou travailleront avec le
président de la République pour
déterminer quelle est la meilleure tête
de liste pour porter les valeurs de la
majorité présidentielle pour vous je
n'ai pas d'idée et je n'ai pas de de nom
à vous donner ça sera un choix du
président de la République et des chefs
de parti on va continuer à parler
d'Emmanuel Macron puisqueaprès vous
avoir reçu hier il tiendra une
conférence de presse ce soir à 20h15
pour donner le cap de la seconde partie
de son quinquena que peut-on en attendre
on voit ça avec Quentin
[Musique]
calm bonjour Quentin bonjour Arian
bonjour Xav Covelli bonjour et Quentin
on le disait deuxème étape pour le chef
de l'État après les parlementaires à la
majorité hier l'Élysée hier pardon
Emmanuel Macron convoque la presse ce
soir voilà c'est en plus un format
inédit ce soir choisi pour cette grande
conférence de presse depuis 2017
Emmanuel Macron a eu très peu recours à
cet exercice il n'aime pas cette
confrontation avec les journalistes
contrairement à François Hollande par
exemple donc la dernière fois
qu'Emmanuel Macron a réalisé une telle
conférence de presse c'était le 25 avril
2019 à la fin du mouvement des gilets
jaunes pour présenter les mesures
retenues après le grand débat en 2019 la
conférence de presse avait duré 2h30
mais c'était déroulé dans l'après-midi
c'est dans cette conférence de presse en
2019 qu'il a notamment annoncer la fin
de l'ENA ou encore la généralisation des
maisons France service différence ce
soir le chef de l'État s'exprime à 20h15
en prime time donc une première pour
parler effectivement au plus grand
nombre c'est en cela que ce rendez-vous
est inédit orienne les équipes du chef
de l'État qui promettent depuis le début
de la semaine une conférence de presse
XXL c'était donc ça le rendez-vous avec
la nation promis en décembre alors
Quentin est-ce qu'on peut attendre des
annonces dans cette conférence de presse
difficile à dire l'idée de présenter un
cap vous le disiez enien pour le nouveau
gouvernement annoncé vendredi dernier
sans doute revenir aussi sur la
nomination de Gabriel Attal un peu
plusutôt dans la semaine également
tenter de clore la séquence sur le
projet de loi immigration quielle
laisser des traces au sein de la
majorité présidentielle seule difficulté
si le président va trop loin dans les
annonces il pourrait donner la sensation
d'éclipser son premier ministre en effet
Gabriel hatal n'a toujours pas fait son
discours de politique générale qui est
pourtant le moment où est fixé la
feuille de route de l'exécutif devant le
Parlement c'est ce que disaent
d'ailleurs les oppositions hier écoutez
par exemple le député de la France
insoumise manuel bonpard ce qui est le
plus frappant et le plus choquant c'est
qu'on a désormais un nouveau Premier
ministre qu'on est en attente d'un
discours de politique générale et qu'on
a l'impression que finalement c'est le
président de la République qui va faire
le discours de politique générale même
chose pour le rassemblement national
Sébastien Chenu dénoncé hier sur Public
Sénat l'inélégance du président de la
République vis-à-vis de son premier
ministre à qui il coupe l'herbe sous le
pied comme en 2017 avec Édouard Philippe
d'ailleurs écoutez la suite le président
de la République nous a déjà habitué à
ces formats parce qu'on nous dit c'est
une conférence de presse XXL assez
superlatif qui à la fin ne débouche sur
rien moi je me souviens et je garde un
mauvais souvenir des débats des gilets
jaunes on disait c'est des heures de
débats il a parlé de tout et à la fin
que reste-t-il de tout cela rien donc
non nous n'attendons rien mais je crois
que les Français n'attendent pas
grand-chose du président de la
République alors Xavier Covelli
qu'est-ce que vous répondez déjà à
l'argument sur l'inélégance de la part
du chef de l'État envers son premier
ministre déjà cette ce rendez-vous avec
la nation il est annoncé depuis
longtemps il s'inscrit dans une séquence
à la fois des vœux du président de la
République de du remanement et puis
maintenant ce grand rendez-vous avec la
nation avant la reprise des des travaux
au Parlement il s'inscrit aussi si à une
semaine de du discours de politique
générale du Premier ministre c'est c'est
mardi c'est confirmé vous nous vous nous
le dites je P ser un scoop mais en tout
cas effectivement il y a le discours de
politique général qui aura lieu la
semaine prochaine par Gabriel Atal
devant le Parlement et c'est tout à fait
normal et donc personne ne peut
s'étonner aujourd'hui on n'est pas en
période de cohabitation que le Président
de la République puisse fixer le cap
puisse avoir ce rendez-vous un peu
gaulien si pe permettre devant la nation
avec la presse et puisse effectivement
fixer le cap pour son gouvernement il le
fixe il l'a fixé pendant le remaniement
et notamment pendant la première réunion
du du Conseil des ministres c'est normal
qu'il puisse fixer ce cap avec avec les
Français et après il y aura la
concrétisation par le Premier ministre
devant les parlementaires devant le
Parlement sur la feuille de route d'ù
cette question est-ce qu'il peut y avoir
des annonces ce que vous dites la
concrétisation ce sera dans le discours
de politique générale donc rien de
concret ce soir mais il peut le
président de la République peut très
bien faire des annonces et après que ça
soit détaillé dans le discours de
politique générale du Premier ministre
il a donné un certain nombre de de de de
de séquences et de projets pour 2024 je
pense notamment à la question de l'IVG
je pense question de la fin de vie sur
les soins palliatifs euh on va dire que
sur fin janvier où on va avoir un grand
plan sur les soins palliatives avant une
loi sur sur la fin de vie sur la
question de l'énergie aussi que nous
avons négocié à l'échelle européenne
notamment avec Ann espag runaché qui sur
la pour nous permettre de maîtriser le
coût de l'énergie pour les Français tout
ce sont des projets si vous voulez qui
sont importants pour 2024 importants
pour les Français et donc oui il va à
mon avis avoir un certain nombre
d'annonces sur ce sujet sur sur la fin
de vie parce qu'il y avait un peu un
flou sur le le contenu du texte du coup
ce que vous a dit le chef de l'État
hierè c'est qu'il y aurait un plan soin
palliatif en janvier et derrière un
texte de loi uniquement sur l'aideactive
à mourir tout à fait fé tout à fait en
février il y aura le texte de loi mais
on sépare bien la partie soins
palliatifs un réarmement en fait des
soins palliatifs qui existent dans notre
pays mais qui sont insuffisants
je crois que le dernier plan on avait 26
départements sur dans sur notre
territoire qui n'avaient pas d'unité de
soins palliatif et donc on a besoin
aujourd'hui de mettre les moyens pour
accompagner les la ministre firmanbodo
s'était engagé à ce qu'il n'y ait plus
de département
sur la concrétisation c'est c'est la
concrétisation effectivement de ces
annonces donc il y aura un grand plan
annoncé par le président de la
République fin janvier et cette fameuse
loi sur la fin de vie qui est le
résultat de discussion transpartisan
depuis un certain nombre de mois la
conférence la convention citoyenne
également est-ce qu'on peut attendre des
annonces en matière de réforme des
institutions ça a été aussi quelque
chose qui a été évoqué dans les articles
vous pensez que ça peut avir il a dit
notamment notamment il avait chargé
Catherine vaterin avant qu'elle soit
ministre de travailler sur la question
de la décentralisation et donc il y aura
un nouvel acte de décentralisation il a
chargé maintenant le garde des saut de
pouvoir porter ses réformes je pense
qu'il est important aussi il l'a dit de
revoir la question du millefeuille de
réduire aussi le miille-feuille
institutionnel de faire en sorte qu'il y
ait une clarification des compétences et
moi sortant des élections sénatoriales
je peux vous dire que c'était très
attendu par les élus locaux et par les
collectivités locales donc P que c'est
très important qu'on puisse avoir cet
acte de décentralisation qui sera quand
même attendu et inédit depuis un certain
nombre d'années lors du précédent
rendez-vous similaire en 2019 le
président avait promis le plein emploi
en 2025 et de ne pas toucher à l'âge de
départ à la retraite ça participe aussi
de la prudence peut-être des Français
devant leur télévision ce soir non enfin
le plein emploi je pense que on y est
presque enfin on n pas encore compè B
sens hein oui ça s ENF
pardonz-mo aujourd'hui quel est le pays
qui a un niveau de croissance le pays
européens qui a un niveau de croissance
comme la France qui crée autant
d'emplois comme la France et qui
continue malgré tout à baisser et
respecter ses engagements de baisse des
émissions de CO2 donc on voit bien
aujourd'hui qu'on est un pays dynamique
attractif pour l'économie on crée de
l'emploi ce qui n'était pas le cas euh
pendant des années et dans les
précédents gouvernements et donc oui euh
la question du plein emploi elle est
toujours dans le dans le viseur malgré
les crises que nous traversons et malgré
euh le les les crises que le pays peut
peut avoir depuis quelques années
maintenant je reviens un mot sur ce que
vous nous avez dit sur la
décentralisation est-ce que ça veut dire
qu'il y a un échelon euh qui va
disparaître en tout cas le président de
la République a parlé de millefeuilles
donc à partir du moment où on s'attaque
aux millefeuilles il faut peut-être
enlever des feuilles mais et ben ça ça
sera toutes les discussions et tout le
travail que le le garde des
sousministres la justice Éric du pont
monéti va mener avec les collectivités
locales avec les représentants
d'association et avec les les les les
les les décideurs donc oui avec le
parlementaire donc laquelle est en trop
pour vous je vais pas me me prononcer
sur sur ça il y a un certain nombre je
vois par exemple en Île-de-France on a
cinq couches différentes entre la
commune le territoire le département la
métropole la région je pense que
effectivement on peut peut-être en
supprimer une ou deux il a dit d'autres
choses sur la décentralisation le chef
de l'État non c'était en voilà c'était
dans dans les objectifs en tout cas les
priorités l' les les réformes
institutionnelles sur ce sujet-là bien
sûr un mot sur un sujet d'inquiétude
pour les Français c'est la hausse du
prix de l'électricité euh qui sera de 10
% le 1er février est-ce que le chef de
l'État ce soir euh euh devrait annoncer
euh la suppression de cette haoche moi
j'ai pas de j'ai pas d'information à
vous donner là-dessus ce qui nous a
parlé sur la question de l'électricité
c'est justement les négociations que
nous avons eu à l'échelle européenne
pour nous permettre de reprendre la main
les négociations que nous avons eu avec
EDF également pour reprendre la main sur
le prix de l'énergie le prix de
l'électricité pour faire en sorte que
nous n'ayons plus à subir les
augmentations dû à à des situations
externes et c'est aussi pour ça que le
fait d'avoir désindexé le prix de
l'électricité du gaz ça c'est un combat
que nous menons avec la France vis-à-vis
de de l'Europe ça c'est un combat que
nous avons gagné et donc ça c'est aussi
pour préparer l'avenir dernière question
oui une dernière question depuis le
début de la semaine dernière Bruno Le
Maire parle de du fait de désendetter la
France que ça va être une des des
priorités de lui son cap à Bery là ce
matin dans la voie du Nord il dit que
dans les prochains jours il va présenter
au président de la République au Premier
ministre des pistes pour dendetter la
France on s'attend à une année 2024 qui
va être difficile vous le pensez on
faire des économie ça va forcément mais
forcément on on l'a jamais caché on a
aujourd'hui on doit rembourser le quoi
qu'il en coûte on doit rembourser un
certain nombre d'endettement que la
France a contracté pour protéger les
Français et donc il va falloir faire des
choix oui qu vous le savez j'ai pas vous
verrez ce soir moi j'ai pas de piste et
en l'occurrence le plan proposé par par
Bruno LEM n'est pas encore présenté au
président de la République donc je lui
laisserai la primeur de ses annonces
merci Quentin il est impatient Quentin à
tout à l'heure à tout à l'heure
effectivement on continuera à parler
effectivement de cette rencontre hier
avec les parlementaires ce sera suiv
dans le club on va parler dansun des
sujets prioritaire d'Emmanuel Macron
c'est la question de l'école c'est
l'actualité dans nos régions on va à
Montpellier où on retrouve Vincent Coste
bonjour B Vincent merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous journaliste au Midi Libre
Vincent avec vous on va parler de
l'école et plus précisément de
l'uniforme à l'école puisque la ville de
ber veut l'expérimenter très vite
oui tout à fait alors le maire de Baer
Robert Ménard est attaché à cette idée
puisqu'il avait dès
2014 vous proposer le le port de la
blouse dans les dans les écoles de
béziier là il s'est rallé à l'idée émise
par gabrielal qui parle lui de tenue
vestimentaire unque et d'une d'une
campagne d'expérimentation qui va durer
2 ans à partir de la rentrée de
septembre 2024 mais Robert Menard le
maire de Bézier a décidé de devancer
l'appel et l'expérimentation il va la
lancer dès le 26 février au retour des
au retour des vacances d'hiver auprès de
quatre écoles de Bézier les conseils
d'écoes ont ont voté on on ont accepté
de participer à cette expérimentation et
c'est 719 élèves exactement qui p
porteront donc une tenue vestimentaire
unique à la rentrée à Bézier dans ces
quatre écoles tenue vestimmentaire qui
sera composé je crois d'un blazer et
ensuite au choix bermuda pantalon
pantalon ou jupe sur le sur le plan du
du financement c'est c'est un trousseau
de d'une valeur de 200 € qui sera remis
à à chaque à chaque famille enfin à
chaque élève en tout cas trousseau qui
est financé
pour moitié par par la ville de Bézier
pour moitié par l'État Vincent on a on a
des petits soucis de son est-ce que vous
pouvez poser votre question du coup à
Xavier yacovelli
oui justement je voulais lui je voulais
lui demander d'abord s'il était s'il
était en phase lui venu venu de venu de
la gauche c'est pas c'est pas toujours
de de de ce camp là que l'on retrouvait
la plus la la la la volonté le plus la
plus farouche de revenir à à l'uniforme
ou à une tenue vestimentaire unique
est-ce qu'il était en phase avec ce avec
ce ce choix de de Gabriel Atal notamment
lorsqu'il était lors de son passage au
ministère de de l'éducation et ce qu'
trouve pertinent de de l'expérimenter au
plus vite de dévenser l'appel tel que le
fait le le le le maire de ber robertmena
oui bonjour Alors moi depuis le le début
depuis que Gabriel Atal était ministre
de l'éducation nationale j'ai soutenu
cette proposition parce que déjà je
pense que euh il faut se donner tous les
moyens pour trouver des solutions pour
améliorer le climat à l'école pour
lutter contre lehcèlement pour aussi
répondre à un des fondements de l'école
de la République c'est-à-dire l'égalité
des chances et donc si
l'expérimentation de l'uniforme ou de
oui de l'uniforme à l'école peut
permettre de régler ces problèmes en
tout cas de répondre à ces problèmes moi
j'y suis favorable c'est d'ailleurs pour
ça que le ministre enfin le Premier
ministre qui était ministre de
l'éducation nationale
avait lancé cette expérimentation pour
2024 pour nous permettre à la fois de ne
fermer aucune porte et de se dire si ça
fonctionne et ben tant mieux on
généralisera mais en tout cas il il ne
faut fermer aucune porte pour pouvoir
essayer d'améliorer la situation et et
moi je vois ce n pas une question de
gauche de droite moi je vois un certain
nombre de communes qui se lancent
aujourd'hui dans l'expérimentation voulu
par le le Premier ministre je pense à la
commune de Denin dans dans le Nord avec
une mère socialiste qui est ancienne
député socialiste d'ailleurs et qui
lance l'expéri entation de de l'uniforme
à l'école moi honnêtement je pense que
ça peut être un un un bel outil de
d'égalité des chances et et
d'amélioration du climat scolaire et de
lutte contre le harcèlement à l'école
merci Vincent on regarde votre une la
une du midil prof absent qui dit vrai en
référence à la polémique suscitée par
Amélie oua cerra un mot évidemment
xavacovelli sur cette polémique sur la
scolarisation de ses enfants dans le
privé et sur la justification qu'elle en
a faite d'un trop grand nombre d'heures
non remplacé dans dans le public hier
elle a demandé de clore le chapitre des
attaques personnelles est-ce qu'elle
peut se contenter de ça après ses propos
est-ce qu'elle a fait une erreur
honnêtement je pense que on est dans un
dans une hypocrisie aujourd'hui les 3/4s
des oppositions qui critiquent la la
sortie de de de la ministre de
l'éucation nationale et des Sports euh
mettent leurs enfants dans le privé donc
c'est un choix personnel sincèrement je
pense que déjà attaquer la ministre sur
des choix personnels de vie avec ses
avec ses enfants je trouve que ça n'a
pas de sens c'est indécent justification
qui visiblement n'est pas réelle en plus
moi ce que je vois aujourd'hui c'est
peut-être aussi le malaise cette
polémique av vient aussi peut-être du
malaise de certaines oppositions qui ont
du mal à accepter que le ministre de
l'éducation nationale Gabriel Atal
lorsqu'il est arrivé aux responsabilités
a mis trois fois plus de remplaçants à
la rentrée de de septembre 2023 et c'est
ça la réalité c'est-à-dire que oui
effectivement on peut pas nier qu'il y a
eu des problèmes on peut pas nier qu'il
y en est encore et par contre on voit
que la sur la base du
de volontarisme du du Premier ministre
mais est- est pas mal prise le Premier
ministre a fait en sorte effectivement
qu'on puisse remplacer qu'on metre les
moyens pour avoir des remplaçants parce
que c'est un une réalité on a aussi des
problèmes parfois de remplacement quel
que soit le public ou dans le privé et
donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut qu'on
puisse mettre les moyens et le paquet
sur l'école c'est ce que fait le premier
ministre sous la demande du Président de
la République merci xacovelli merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin dans